Basheer Amma has a lot of time on his
hands to talk shop with a club soccer
trainer Bashir used to make a lot of
money by helping migrants across the
Sahara Desert all the way to Libya but
when the government cracked down on
people smugglers Bashir decided to call
it quits he now helps fund the city's
biggest soccer club this is the club of
people smugglers I'm a people smuggler
the Vice President is a people smuggler
and so is everyone who's in charge here
and so with the investors his experience
as a smuggler comes in handy for
Basheer's latest business deal eight of
his players are migrants who had been
stranded in Agadez where Bashir
recruited them for his team player 66
from Ivory Coast also once dreamed of
becoming a soccer superstar in Europe
instead Muhammadu now plays for Bashir's
club efforts this season wasn't going so
well but next season it's going to be
better but sure now tries to prevent
them from making the trek to Europe
mostly because it's in his own interest
they are his top players after all but
also because more and more ruthless
gangs are taking over new shares
trafficking business the routes are
checked everywhere at the moment that's
why the traffickers take different
routes through the desert and they're
very dangerous the traffickers and
Agadez have always worked in legal limbo
but many like Bashir were reputable
businessmen about two years ago however
Europe urged Nazaire to pass a law
against people smuggling they imposed
hefty fines for transporting migrants in
almost all cases it turned into a
business that became too dangerous for
many the only visitors at trafficker
Mohammed's office are former colleagues
who are now without a job mohamed
stopped updating information on routes
and destinations a long time ago bukka
deaths were done it's finished there's
nothing in a cadet
no one could do any kind of business
here no
one can sell anything according to human
trafficking experts the more established
people smugglers and agadez were also
partly responsible for the deaths of
many migrants but the brutality of the
business has picked up since the new
gangs have taken over about 5,000
migrants have died in the desert just
this year alone they were abducted or
abandoned by their traffickers many took
dangerous little known routes through
the sahara in nazareth north-east Bashir
takes us to one of the hidden desert
cities just outside of Anka des where
many of the new gangs are operating from
it's said to be ruled by the mafia
that's a business that's done in secrecy
and people will continue doing that
everyone knows cocaine is illegal but
the people still take it this visit is
not without risk for the former people
smuggler relations with the new guys are
understandably strained but he says he's
well-connected so they won't harm him
he's mostly interested in scouting
talent among the hundreds of stranded
migrants who ran out of money to
continue their travels many have been
stuck here for months but nothing seems
to deter them from their journey my
final destination is Europe no matter
what obstacles I run into I'm not afraid
I'm only going to die once in the end
Bashir manages to find a potential
soccer player from Ivory Coast and
invites him to come to tryouts
it's where he will have to prove he has
enough talent to play for new share
second division and most importantly
whether he is ready to give up his dream
of Europe for now